I think it's a combination of factors
it's a combination of a growing
disenchantment with the Western project
essentially which I think is in the
beginning of grabbing a Putin's rule it
was quite enthusiastic about and
certainly wanted its Russia to play a
part in Western structures that because
now that braces don't think he feels
that way it's all love you think that
Russia has its own role to play in the
world and I think he's motivated by
economic factors but I think the
economic factors are primarily to do
with for the safeguarding stability at
home anyway Putin and his governments
are very concerned about is the
weakening a bit on power and he's that
sort of feed into another driver of his
actions which is building a kind of
national identity attach your experience
at home that had Moya his government's
and Moya how confident Russians feel
about being Russian and if you can do
that effectively there he can I think
enjoyed more long five years in power
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook